au cinéma avec carte est vieille et
toujours un petit événement lorsque
johnny hallyday tourner dans un film
cette fois s'il joue un garden prison à
la santé chargée de la surveillance d'un
grand escroc marie-jo joie et nadine
picards ont rencontré la rock star à
cannes johnny hallyday à cannes loin de
la cohue
c'était pour la promotion de quartier
vip dans lequel il incarne un gardien de
prison
un rôle de composition qui ne pouvait
que séduire ses footings présentait alex
break qu'elle va redire ce matin en
place jeu il est beau plus fort tout à
fait mon genre un gardien de prison
chargé de surveiller la crème de la
crème des bureaux au cardié spécialement
aménagé pour eux qui voient plus moi
surtout c'était de pouvoir faire évoluer
le personnage d'un maton à quai à
quelqu'un qui est propulsé comme ça dans
dans un petit peu dans la jet set j'ai
juste besoin de vous pour me venger de
ma femme
alex maintenant désabusé devenu le temps
d'une arnaque grand patron vous séduire
la femme du célèbre prisonnier qu'il
surveille ne crois pas qu'on va se faire
opérer l'homme
l'occasion de re découvrir johnny acteur
il a déjà quinze films à son actif
en fait je t'ai pas dit mais à cause de
ma mutation quartier réalité je vais
être obligé de suivre un stage de
l'écologie carcéral c'est quoi cette
histoire
ils vous font faire des stages de
formation après 25 ans de métier je n'ai
jamais vraiment satisfait de son âge sur
les grands écrans d'hulu douloureux de
ce palais des acteurs qui vont jamais
voir les films qu'ils ont qu'ils ont
tourné au jeu mais surtout parce que ça
m'intéresse de ne plus faire la même
erreur la fois d'après henry hassid
mattel sont bons alors c'est une société
immobilière aux bahamas
évidemment c'est une la blanchisserie
d'argent à des investisseurs comme clair
ça les intéresse parce qu'on sent
pourtant ici que le célèbre rockeur
acteur s'est fait plaisir avec françois
berléand
ils forment un sacré duo ce que orchies
tous ensemble m'emmerde battant je veux
ma